cette visite je vais vous proposer un
petit masque pour justement d occulter
votre vision est que vous ne soyez guidé
que par ma voix et par les différents
objets ces deux personnes sont des
professionnels du tourisme
elles sont venues expérimenté le
quotidien d'un déficient visuel c'est le
cas de peguy elle découvre ici une
reproduction d'un objet en 3d
c'est extraordinaire je trouve de
pouvoir découvrir des oeuvres en les
touchant parce qu'habituellement dans
les musées vont toucher avec les yeux et
puis là on a droit d'y mettre les mains
donc je trouve ça se trouve ça vraiment
bien pour les personnes concernées vous
pensez que c'est un plus ah oui
complètement complètement bien sûr dans
cette salle par exemple les oeuvres
s'adapte au public en situation de
handicap c'est un bas relief en calcaire
réalisée par l'artiste florentin brideau
qui représente un faucon fait oeuvre en
fête a été reproduite à l'identique en
3d de manière à permettre aux personnes
déficientes visuelles de pouvoir suivre
les contours justement de l'oeuvre et
cette oeuvre va être accompagnée d'une
audiodescription plus adroite de l'oeil
donc on va remonter vous allez voie la
plus à droite de l'oeil ou c'était
comment mais très étonnant parce qu'en
fait baisser une oeuvre que je connus un
mec que j'ai plaisir à redécouvrir en la
touchant des professionnels du tourisme
qui pourront désormais faire la
promotion de ce concept auprès des
visiteurs un dispositif précieux pour
rendre la culture accessible à tous